[Music]
good sound test
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is caleb denby
and i will be your driver on this
journey
uh tonight i want to have some fun and
look at some of the oldest recorded
chess games
so these games are a lot of fun because
people weren't very good at chess when
these were recorded uh and so we'll have
a lot of fun looking at some exciting
attacks and seeing
where players were going wrong before
the 1600s even rolled about or were way
way way in in the past
so the first one i want to look at is i
believe the oldest recorded chess game
that is is still around that people know
about it's between and forgive me for my
pronunciation francesco d castelvi
and narcisso and video lace videoless
something like that
um
well and i say it's between these two
players really this is not the oldest
chess game ever played because it was
composed i believe it's kind of an
interesting interesting story behind
this game it was actually written into a
poem and written in the valencian
language there is a poem where the chess
game is an allegory for this like love
story it's kind of kind of weird i
couldn't find a translation of the poem
so i don't really fully understand how
it's supposed to make sense but the
point of the story this game is supposed
to reflect some some kind of of love
story so let's let's look at it the the
oldest chess game anyone knows about and
what else but the scandinavian very uh
very weird opening to pick uh for the
first chess game ever recorded
and we get queen takes d5 and that's
what makes this game um like i said the
oldest chess game ever recorded back in
the olden days queens couldn't do this
queens used to be super super weak they
used to only move diagonally one space
at a time and then these people um
in valencia were like nah super powerful
piece queens can move in any direction
as far as they want and that was the
development that pretty much led us to
two modern chess
so queen takes d5 played we get knight
to c3 and so far so good normal
scandinavian stuff now of course queen
a5 is a line but um in this game we see
black just retreating back to d8
so now you know with the benefit of 600
years uh longer no 600 years or so of
chess theory we know that pawn to d4 is
one of the main main lines here and
white is going to try to take over the
center uh get a little bit of extra
space and play with that space
instead we get bishop c4
uh by white which is also
a fine move y just develops out black
plays knight f6 we get knight f3 and so
far so normal this actually shockingly
resembles modern chess so far and then
black plays this move bishop to g4
and this is where uh the age of the game
starts to show so this is our first huge
mistake in the game does anyone see
what's wrong with the move bishop to g4
yeah so there are actually a couple ways
to take advantage but bishop takes f7 is
going to be
a big big problem here so this is a
tactic hopefully you guys have seen
before but i assume it's a tactic that
these two players had never seen before
because no one had ever seen this tactic
before of course we draw the king
forward and then this pin turns out to
be a discovered attack uh the classic
reversal and this knight attacks both
pieces
so we'll pick up our piece back on on g4
now there's actually another really
really strong move which is potentially
even better than bishop takes f7 so
let's see if you guys can can find that
one
knight to e5 yeah it's exactly right so
um
i guess this somewhat resembles uh is it
legal's mate where we we can sacrifice
our queen
uh and the point is this king is left
with nowhere to run trapped by his own
pieces and we can just get checkmate
right right away
um but francesco didn't write either of
those moves into the poem instead he
just chose this move h3 black goes ahead
and captures on f3 okay queen takes f3
and now another pretty big mistake e6 by
black so this mistake is a little bit
easier to refute we don't even need any
tactics
we can just take this b7 pawn and now
black is in big trouble
okay so pawn on b7 is hanging we take it
black develops at the knight defending
this rook on e8
so let's see
how we can continue to press here for a
big big advantage white is doing very
very well
but if you just play some sort of normal
looking move like d3 or d4
maybe black is gonna have time
to develop his pieces
and uh
get back into this game so how do we
keep up the pressure
how can we keep up the pressure here
okay so bishop b5 is one option but
remember our our goal here is to stop
black from developing so if black gets
fully developed yeah white's going to be
up a pawn and will probably be a bit
better especially with the bishops
but if you just do something like bishop
b5 maybe you haven't stopped black after
all it's bishop d6 and castles on the
next turn
what else can we do
we want to play
very actively here we're going to keep
making threats
not give our opponent a chance to
breathe
any ideas
yeah so knight p5 i i think is the best
move and yeah probably black should
still play this move bishop to d6
uh but now we're actually going to have
quite quite a quite a few options here
we could even consider
um taking this pawn on a7 just going up
a second pawn
and if black does something like castles
we can come to c6 with this knight can
even come back to b5 with this knight
we have other options as well we can
just take off this bishop
and keep up the pressure just and yeah
black is going to get castled but now
we've sort of removed black's best minor
piece and in that bishop on d6 that was
pretty strong and white's just going to
be a lot better so i think knight p5 is
is by far the the best idea here you
know you could play something like d4
and like i said you will just be better
in these positions
um but you know your queen is sort of
sidelined you probably need to bring
this piece back
and black is going to stay in the game
right has ideas of going e5 or something
breaking in the center keeping his his
rook active as well
it's still going to be a fight whereas
after knight b5 i think black does just
get into immediate trouble again i think
probably just knight takes a seven and
you're up two pawns
it's gonna be a tough tough fight if you
go knight c5 i have this check as well
as this check probably this one is
simpler and yeah it's going to be really
really tough
so
after knight b5 rather than bishop d6
which i think is probably the best move
um nerciso goes rook to c8
so obviously if after bishop bishop d6
knight takes a7 is good move probably a
pretty good move here and that's what
francesco decides to play
um we get knight to b6 offering up this
rook
um white takes it as he should
uh if rook to b8 were to be played
i i think white is still just completely
winning we can just drop our queen back
to some square really i think any square
this one maybe 95 is a problem so maybe
something like 26 but
obviously black should should save the
rook instead knight knight to b6
um and maybe nobody had ever told
arsysto that rooks were worth more than
knights maybe nobody had figured that
out yet but francesco had that idea so
he captured the rook on c8
uh you get knight takes c8
um and now d4 which is uh a pretty good
move white just wants to get the the
remaining pieces into the game
and try to to go after this black king
of course we just have a winning
advantage at this point with our extra
material
and our save for king
black goes knight d6
bishop b5 check it's a good response
queen check is also fine
takes takes knight to d7
and white plays this really weird
looking move d5
um this move doesn't really spoil
anything but it's it's just sort of an
interesting idea
um
the point for white is i guess he's
trying to open up these files but
probably better is just to develop your
pieces no reason to do this this kind of
fancy stuff
so takes bishop e3 is played
and now bishop d6 and now this is a
really interesting moment in in the game
for me so white to move here what do you
think the the best move
is
what is the best move it's not like a
crazy tactic or anything but it's the
best move for us
of course like everything is winning
but
yeah okay i mean it's kind of a silly
question you can take the pawn you can
you can really do anything
um but as someone in the chat says i
think the best way to continue here is
to actually long castle inside castles
the reason is we just get a rook under
this nice file we get our king to safety
and now black is is just in a bad way
um
and i find this moment in the game
really interesting because white played
the move rook to d1 which is much like
queen side castles but it's sort of
worse in every way right we just would
rather have our king on c1
and so that's why i'm gonna potentially
argue that this is not the oldest game
of chess recorded even though everybody
considers it as such
because nobody castles in the game and i
think this move is pretty reasonable
evidence you know i think even back then
they would have understood that getting
the king to c1 would be better here
so i think it's pretty reasonable
evidence that maybe they were playing a
version of the game where castling was
was not allowed
um which you know makes it not chess
that being said though rook d1 played uh
in the game we get queen to f6 now by
black and now white's just going to be
breaking through rick takes d5 queen g6
and now we get the funniest move of the
game
bishop to f4 so
uh francesco i think came up with this
little tactic and was quite happy with
himself of course this is just a bad
move white should just castle like
should you know do do anything get the
remaining pieces in the game and then
win but instead bishop to f4 so of
course what's the problem
with bishop f4 what's the idea and and
what's the problem
any thoughts yet
yeah
so
so even worse than queen takes g2 uh
queen takes you two is probably
like an okay try for black but
yeah we we just go queen e4 check
and now we are threatening to take this
bishop and so if you go bishop e3 now g2
hangs and okay white is probably
actually still winning
but obviously we've spoiled quite a bit
with our little trick however the ending
is good for francesco uh bishop takes up
war gets played in the game and now who
sees checkmate in two
anybody
go ahead and just shout it out if you
see it
queen takes knight king f8
and of course queen d8
is checkmate
um
a perfect checkmate i believe as well um
i don't know if perfect is or there's
there's some word for a checkmate where
every square that the king can go to is
is covered exactly one time and this is
an example of that kind of checkmate and
the oldest recorded chess game
uh so lots of fun so this game is is
kind of a lot of nonsense but you can
see sort of a a glimmer of of chess
strategy already kind of forming right
they all very very quickly tried to get
their pieces into the game and they even
uh had their play kind of revolving
around the center for a little bit now
obviously a lot of tactics and ideas
were missed
but you know they're they're playing
chess and i
let me double check the year
yeah this was 14 1475
when this game was was recorded
so pretty pretty old
now that being said i want to move from
this to the first games of chess uh ever
actually played and written down before
i do that any questions on on this one
the oldest game of chess ever
any questions
okay
fair enough
now
let's move on to a player you guys might
have heard of uh has anyone here heard
of damiano
pedro damiano
ben's nodding yes
the class not so much
you've heard of him yeah so damiano is
one of those guys that uh was
one of the the first players to
write down his chess games i'm sure
other people were playing chess games
but damiana was one of the ones that
wrote his down and so that's why he is
forever famous
now you might also have heard of the
damiano defense which of course i
believe
goes e4
e5
knight f3
f6 so kind of fitting that a terrible
terrible terrible opening is named after
damiano because they didn't know better
backhand back then they said ah pawns
attacks probably you need to defend it
with another pawn f6 but of course
what's wrong with this move is knight
takes e5 when you actually cannot
recapture
because this is going to give you a very
very difficult time g6 and
you're immediately losing your stuff
but we don't get to see the damiano
defense in this game even though damiano
is playing instead we get knight f6 the
petrov
uh and in response we get knight takes
e5
and of course in this position the move
d6 is required
we need to kick this knight away before
we can recapture on e4 this is petrov
101 instead though black plays this move
knight takes e4 so who remembers the
problem with with knight takes e4
the copycat strategy
did not work out for black
yeah we go queen to e2
now of course if you try to save this
knight
what happens here
yeah d3
and if we move the knight away
right knight c6 is check and the queen's
attacks and the queen can't block
because the knight also attacks that
square
um so
you might have heard that this just like
loses by force and black is is just
busting but kind of incredibly uh no
name very famous player from the olden
days played a ton of games mr no name
um finds the the best way to continue
here with black that black actually does
not have to resign after this knight
takes e4 move black can can keep the
game going
and no name finds the way to do it with
this move queen to e7
so of course white captures this knight
on e4 but now what's what's the problem
uh what does black do here to regain the
piece
no not knight c6 um
okay maybe maybe you can try this this
move but uh
white's going to play something like d4
and
and i think
that gets you into trouble
you just want to go d6 right away
and the point here is that black is
getting the piece back but white is
gonna be gonna be a little bit better so
uh damiano plays d4 so so far domino is
playing like a perfect game he's the
best
uh and now of course black does actually
need to capture this pawn or this knight
on e5 and white is going to temporarily
be up a pawn
it turns out this pawn is kind of
difficult to hold on to though black can
just pile on the pressure and the best
way to continue with white here is just
develop your pieces
you get into a position like this and
white's just going to play something
like bishop f4
and
potentially pick up this pawn on c7
unless you play bishop d6
and black's pieces are just going to be
pretty awkward white is
ahead in development and is going to
have a pretty significant plus because
of that but again you know black's
black's not resigning
instead black was very very very greedy
so rather than taking the knight and
giving up a pawn black decided to go
with um f6 here
and go come after this knight right away
so this position is very very bad for
for black but only one move
really
um
gets the maximum advantage you know
white can play normally and be a lot
better because black has played this f6
move
but
white has some ideas here that put black
in immediate danger so wait to move here
what's the best way to keep up the
pressure and punish our opponent
again this might not be like a knockout
tactic but one way to continue is is
better than the rest
okay yeah bishop b5 is is a perfectly
reasonable move but black is probably
going to play c6 just get the tempo back
against the bishop
we can play something here that creates
two threats in the position and that's
why black is
it's gonna really struggle
so what threats are you trying to make
with bishop c4
yeah something like bishop f7 yeah so
you know bishop c4 does create a threat
bishop f7 is is kind of nasty but you
know black can can parry this just by
taking the knight i think
what do you think brian
there should be two
um
how so
right
any other ideas
yeah knight c3 is the nasty move that
that black can't really deal with
so what are the the two threats that
we've made
right so first of all we've defended our
queen which means that this is no longer
a pin so if black does like nothing we
can bring the knight back be up a full
piece
so this means that black is more or less
required to capture this knight if you
don't capture this knight we'll save the
knight be up a piece
but what does that allow us to do next
what's the second idea behind knight c3
this one kind of is just tactically
winning here
maybe just switching next to five
it's exactly right
so if this had happened in the game
and black tries to
take let's say
uh with the f pawn
we go knight d5
now we're threatening c7 and the queen
and to take on e5 and this queen
actually
has a very tough time touching both both
of these squares so if queen d7
take e5
threatening to take d6 and just winning
the game
if you go this way
then that's going to be even worse
same with uh
okay there's really no other squares
same with d8 we're just going to take
here and and black is in a bad way so
knight to c3 would have been really
really killer in in this game instead
damiana goes f4 which doesn't actually
make a whole lot of sense i think
um
i think the the players are sort of just
dealing with what they see on the board
they see that ah my opponent uh attacked
this this square again so i'm no longer
winning a pawn after captures
right black keeps this pawn so damiano
was like i'll defend the square again
and now if he takes
i get to win a pawn gloriously so i
think that was the idea but of course
better just to develop the pieces here
just get your pieces into the game
and and you'll be doing well better than
f4 would have been yes this bishop e5
move bishop d3 bishop e3
should be two all of those just
developing moves i think give white a
pretty significant plus
instead though we go f4
and black goes knight to d7 you know
we're renewing the threat to the the
knight we'll say
um now damiano does find this idea of
knight to c3 and that's where the
trouble really starts for uh for black
black takes uh the knights because that
was threat number one and then damiano
executes threat number two so we found
this knight c3 idea just just to move
too late
um
but it it didn't cost in the game
everything still worked out okay now we
get this move queen to d6
um so here
white to move and and basically
basically win
and damiano played the rest of this game
actually very very well his only real
mistake was this f4 move
so black's pieces are stretched very
very very thin
if we do things correctly black's
actually not able to hold on to
everything
in fact we'll see maybe he's not able to
hold on to anything
yep so it takes takes
and yeah and the point is
black actually can't recapture this pawn
and and that's why his position is is so
bad
so queen takes is pretty obvious what's
wrong here we can trade queens
take c7
and take the rook
uh but what's wrong with knight takes
what goes wrong there
that i'm sure was was black's idea
yeah just bishop f4 and again the the
power of development is sort of on full
display as it often is in these older
games the site that's more developed
very often goes on to win the game
just nothing to do about this pin
white's going to win a piece
but no name is a clever guy
he doesn't play either of these moves
actually i got the move order wrong
he goes queen c6 here and now of course
we get the move of the game daniano wins
in style here um showing some pretty
complex tactics for 14.97
yeah bishop b5 it's just nasty
and this queen
is in a bad way
take this bishop knight c7 check
disaster
so no name tried to hold on with queen
to e3 and now damiano forces resignation
his next move
so wait to move
and finish them off
yeah bishop e3 this bishop is still
untouchable
and believe it or not
this queen is entirely trapped
excuse me just absolutely nowhere to go
with this queen every possible square
is covered
and no name throws in the towel resigns
so pretty fun game uh and again yeah
damiano played nearly perfectly it was
just this this f4 move which i guess is
a very human mistake um you know your
thing was attacked so you might as well
defend it
this was really the only the only bad
move by damiana everything else is just
tactics tactics tactics and he
calculated well
so this i think may have been one of the
the first actually played chess games
that that we still have record of
um now i did actually find another game
from 1497 which i think is is a little
bit of a better one this this one's a
lot more fun
and it's by uh
uh lucena so who here has heard of
lucena hopefully almost everybody
so why have we heard of lucena
he's famous for for one thing
the lucena position
yes so of course the senate position is
a position in rook and pawn end games uh
potentially the most
important position to know in rook and
pawn end games
and it's the position where you're
winning when you have an extra pawn in
rooks and nothing else
now i actually couldn't find any record
of him
showing that position writing that down
or playing that position but for some
reason it got named after him um so
that's that's lucena he was actually one
of the first chess players that wrote
down his games along with with damiano
and this one is also from from 1497 so
again another contender for for the
first chess game ever
uh played and then recorded and
something really exciting happens in
this one as we'll see
so e3 move one by no name uh classic no
name throwing things
throwing things into an off b position
we get e5
d4
takes queen takes d4 so of course much
better is to take with the pawn just uh
keeping your claim in the center
said queen takes and lucena goes d5 so
far so good for lucena putting his pawns
in the center taking control
queen d1
and these players from the 1400s are
never one to miss an opportunity to try
to trick the opponent so bishop d6
of course trying to trick no name into
giving up his queen
with queen takes d5 and bishop b4
but no name is wise to the trix goes
nate c3
we go knight f6 just to defense knight
f3 and then lucinda goes ahead and
develops with bishop to e6 so far so so
normal
you get bishop d3 knight c6
b3
and now this weird move h6 but this
actually makes quite a bit of sense so
why do we play h6 what do you think
black is trying to stop here
what's the points
right whenever you put a bishop on e6
um in openings like this and conversely
with white ever puts a bishop on e3
a move you always have to be somewhat
concerned about is the idea of knight to
g5 just harassing this bishop making
this bishop move again and this bishop
kind of needs to be here to help support
the d5 pawn so h6 is a nice move just
um not really a waiting move but just an
improving move stops this knight from
coming to g5
white continues out now with bishop to
b2
and black goes queen to d7 white goes
queen to e2
you know this is why this game is
awesome it's the first game where
someone castles and the first time
castles was ever recorded in a chess
game it was black castling queenside
probably not my pick for what i would
have guessed the first castling move uh
ever recorded was but yeah black
castle's queen side here and now white
castles king side
and so i want to pause and kind of talk
about this position a little bit because
it's
uh really interesting how the
understanding of the players at the time
even you know these were like the the
best chess players as they were the only
ones writing down their games
their understanding kind of lines up
with what you would expect an amateur
player
um
to to sort of think about the position
as well they sort of have similar ideas
about things so what's going on here
we've just castled on opposite sides so
how do you expect the rest of this game
to go what is black going to be trying
to do and what is what is white going to
be trying to do
start with with black's plan and black's
ideas what do we want to try to do here
yeah you want to get after the king so
how would you go about doing that
night h7
and then what's what's the follow-up
like what's what's your idea
yeah so you want to do an eventual pawn
storm right you want to push these pawns
forward get after the white king and
that's exactly
it's actually exactly what lucena was
thinking in the game and he rather than
play knight h7 he just played g5 right
away just decided to start going and
come after
come after the king
it turns out though that that isn't
quite the right way to continue in this
position so
what's wrong with this idea of g5 do you
think like at its core it's it's a good
idea you want to push the pawns you want
to do a pawn storm and go after the king
but there's something pretty seriously
wrong with this move here
right it's not really taking into
account this bishop on b2
and now back in the day i don't think
they had any concept of like end games
really they just thought you know uh
that's where my opponent's king is i'm
gonna go try to take it and win the game
so i'm pretty sure that's what was going
on with luciano years like okay yeah i
need to attack the king and then win
but it leaves behind all these holes and
black is is going to have a really tough
time if white finds this idea of knight
to b5
when you know this is coming and this
knight is active
and here we can even just start start
bringing in more pieces
we're threatening to take and take now
and it's it's going to be really tough
for
for black to deal with this just this
long term dark squared weakness here on
the diagonal
so with that in mind what is a better
way for black to try to continue
if g5 makes too many weaknesses what can
we do
any ideas
yeah okay a move like bishop g4 isn't
isn't terrible and your head's in the
right direction um
if the pawn storm is either too slow or
too weakening you're right in thinking
well then we should attack with the
pieces
so that's that's the idea i was hoping
you guys would would come across is
rather than you know trying to do a pawn
storm with g5 and make all these
weaknesses but i can actually just use
the minor pieces here to really provoke
some some major weaknesses and give
white a ton of problems
so of course as it sits white's uh king
side pawns are undisturbed and they are
sort of at their strongest when they're
undisturbed right they could go you know
white has all options available to him
playing h3 playing g3 playing f3 f4
anything like that anything he needs to
defend the king
so it's always helpful if we can force
our opponent to
disturb these pawns make some weaknesses
something for us to latch on to
so bishop g4 doesn't really do enough
for us i think it uh pins the knight and
that's that's pretty nice but again i
think something like uh knight to b5 is
is probably going to be played and
white's going to be fighting back for
for these dark squares pretty
immediately i think
okay so if we take on h2 i think the
problem is the there's there's just
knight takes right
yeah
but we do want to use
threats against h2 we can use those
those kinds of threats to
to hurt our opponent here
okay did anyone consider
knight to g4 as an idea this i think is
uh the best way for for black to
continue here
and the reason is is pretty simple we're
we're just going to bring in our other
knight next and now all of a sudden
very very serious threats against this
h2 pawn and uh
white is gonna have a very tough time
sort of uh dealing with this
uh just to show an example line let's
let's say knight to b5 gets played again
um
i'm sort of just
playing moves as they they come to me
here let's just say like bishop to e7
uh and now we're going to be able to use
this e5 square i think is is a critical
critical point so okay let's just say
some move
we're gonna play a move like d4 i think
or we can start with this
um
okay i'm gonna cheat
because i don't wanna just like say
nonsense moves
so
oh my god i was so wrong i thought
knight to g4 was the best move
okay i'm the worst ever you guys are the
best ever bishop g4 is is the best here
yeah and knight to g4 apparently knights
to b5 is just a problem uh the idea i
was trying to show is that after a move
like like rook um a to d1 we're going to
continue out now with the knights
and the point i was trying to make is
that we can provoke some weaknesses over
here with something like h3
um and now with more active pieces we
would be able to do this kind of thing
it turns out i was just wrong i don't
know how i messed this up i think i was
looking in a in a different position
uh whoops my bad so you guys are the
best bishop g4 best move and we can
continue out with with knight to e5 and
get after the white the white king
um instead though g5 and yeah now now
black would be in trouble if if knight
to b5 for for all those reasons that uh
that i said
ace a6 and g5
yeah so the
um
the point i was trying to make about
disturbing the pawns over here on the
king side also actually applies to the
pawns in the queen side and in this case
a6 i think is just going to be two
weakening white if not immediately later
on is going to have a ton of ideas of
just snatching this pawn and coming
after coming after the king maybe not
immediately but you know we can prepare
this kind of thing push push some pawns
on the queen inside ourselves
um so yeah g5 and white goes knight to
e1 rather than knight to b5
um now again probably black should
respond to these kinds of threats but
instead he just goes h5
f3 g4
f4 h4 so
so far so good for black he had an idea
he was like ah opposite sides castles i
know an idea i'm gonna push all the
pawns and try to check me
so that's sort of the corollary that i
thought was really interesting because
that's sort of what you do um even even
today you're like yeah i don't know how
else to attack let's just throw all the
pawns at the king and hope for the best
um that being said lucena might have
gotten a little bit carried away here so
white actually can just play this move
f5 and does play this move f5
and this is defended enough times and
this bishop is entirely
entirely trapped
so now lucena goes for broke he goes
with this move h3
and now after takes
um black to move and create
complications so
black is just 100 lost here black lost
to peace white is not checkmated by
force but lucena found a good way to to
kind of make it interesting so
black to move what can we do to
try and make it interesting try and give
our opponents some problems
yeah definitely so
if we're friendly and we just take on e6
white obviously has a lot of things that
he can do but i think something like g3
would be just really uncomfortable for
us oh well i'm sorry this is immediately
winning a queen let's say we take back
like this then then this is also hanging
um so maybe just tactically we kind of
need to do this okay let's say we do
something like queen e7 trying to hold
on to things now again we're going to
run into problems with knight b5 and
this diagonal but also simply g3 is
going to lock down lock down the king's
side and once the king side gets locked
down we're just going to be down a piece
for nothing and probably losing pretty
pretty quickly
um so instead bishop takes h2 is is
probably your best practical try here
you're just ripping things open you're
getting after the king uh well well you
still can't so king takes now we can
take on g2 with check
king takes again
and now dami or lucena goes uh with
queen dd6
so white has a couple ways to defend
here
um and in the game he chooses kind of a
weird one
uh i think probably the simplest is to
come with rook f4
and just try to cut this queen off
completely now black is going to be able
to make some threats with something like
knight h5
um hitting this guy but rick takes g4 is
fine and can also just give up this
piece or this exchange back just to keep
this this queen out of play
um instead though he goes with rook to
h1 which is also winning for white but
it's it's a bit more complex
so black takes off this rook and comes
with rook h8 so now we still have some
attackers and the king lost a defender
king to g1
um so white is still winning here still
up a piece but lucena comes with queen
g3 now
uh and we get knight to g2 so if queen
to g2 uh i think you might have already
blown
the game after queen takes e3
when i think black is escaping with at
least a draw
and you might still get into
even more trouble after something like
like king to a king to f1
how do you get into more trouble
i'm not just i'm not certain maybe rook
h3 maybe this move uh let's move as well
um
ah probably queen to f4 is is the issue
actually now that i see it
and if queen two or sorry queen to f4
and then if queen to f2 we have check
and rook h2
so
probably white has to just take the draw
and that would be the end of the game
so queen to g2 isn't good enough which
is why we get knight to knight to g2
instead now uh lucena does something uh
very modern he brings in more attackers
realizes the queen and the rook aren't
enough so we're going to bring in the
knight to help attack and after queen to
f2 we want to keep the queens on the
board
so we go check
and now g3
and this is the moment where white blows
the game so
white to move here and keep defending
white is still doing well
really only one move that's uh
is even close everything else loses
pretty quickly
yeah so
our hero no name
once again blunders blunders the game
away
no name probably has the worst record in
all of chess even when he's winning
you never want to bet on no name
right queen of g1 is just the only way
to to continue uh you can't allow this
queen to invade with with queen to h1 uh
you're just gonna lose lose right away
so queen to g1 would have been the the
way to continue and um it's still going
to be pretty complicated
for example if knight to f3
i think white is losing pretty major
material in exchange for this pawn but
we have stuff like king to f2
and white should still be doing doing
well
we're gonna sack for this pawn but
whites up a lot of material already
yeah knight one we just take
and if you queen i take it if you take
me i take you
and i have all four minor pieces left
which should be good enough
um
so queen to g1 was just the only way
instead black or white played queen to
f6
and now resigned immediately
i'm just queen h1 queen g2 and this is
this is actually just checkmate just
checkmate go king e1
check
check
and that's that's the game that's the
story
so fees are the only three games that i
know of that were played before the year
1500 or recorded before the year
1500 and they're pretty wildly different
so the the game from the poem i think is
sort of the most nonsense one and then
damiano and lucena both really show a
lot of more modern uh chess ideas you
know they're calculating they're seeing
tactics they're developing in the center
and they're playing some some good
opening ideas
um so any questions on on this game
before i move on to to the last game of
the night here
um
potentially potentially um so this is
the last move that lucena bothered to
record
now sometimes that means that uh they
resigned sometimes that means that the
person writing down the game was just
like now i so obviously won after this
there's no need to write anymore
um and there's a lot of games where you
actually only get a partial game where
they just stops in the middle and then
they write and then white went on to win
um
but yeah this is this is like checkmate
in four or five
so either no name resigned or luciano
was just like yeah clearly clearly i won
the game
yeah
um i mean potentially they did
i don't think i could be wrong i don't
think lucena wrote down white resigns or
something or like white forfeits um i
think it yeah it just writes they just
write that that they won basically is
all they do
um any other questions
so there's an interesting question in
the chat asking how notation was done
back then and i'm not entirely certain
but in general they would
just describe it in in words they would
just say
um the the knight moved to the square
you know in front of this or that this
you know they would just sort of write
it out in in uh
not plain english because that wasn't
written in english but plain
spanish probably in lucenz and lucena's
so algebraic notation is actually a very
very uh modern invention in the form
that we know it um i think in the past
30 years in the late 1980s early 1990s
is when it really came into form
before that they used what was called
descriptive notation which
was much like algebraic notation but
they just instead of using
letters and numbers they would describe
the files by
uh the starting position so this would
be the king's rook file this would be
the king's night sorry queen's rook
queens knight queen's bishop file
queen's file king's file
king's bishop file knight's bishop or
king's night file king's rook file
and they've had that for for quite a
while in some form i'm not sure when
exactly that
did come into form
yeah this
efgh system i think was was in the 80s
when it uh first kind of came to be i
don't know why it took so long to come
up with a grid system for a game played
on a square board but but it did
um
albert in
uh
in the chat says 1475 isn't old you
can't believe that there are no earlier
records of chess games so it's sort of a
technicality there are older records of
games but not with the rule set of chess
that we know today so like at the top of
the lecture i mentioned the queen used
to be a much less powerful piece the
bishops also used to be much less
powerful and this was just the first
recorded game with with this this kind
of rules these these rules that we're
familiar with
so there you go first game where anybody
castles and lucina does it with black
castling queenside
so as fun as those games are i want to
jump forward in time a little bit to a
very very famous uh old chess player by
the name of greco so we're jumping
forward more than a hundred years so
chess has been around a while now people
know a little bit more
and
uh
in most of the games recorded by greco
it's going to look a lot like the
damiano and lucena game where
games end very very quickly they're
decided by checkmate um they they write
down these these flashy games where they
won quickly with a tactic and that's
that's all we really get to see
but i wanted to show this game uh uh
between our hero again no name and and
greco because it shows how ahead of his
time greco was so most you know 98 of of
all the games
are him just like winning really
immediately because the people he's
playing just had no chance
but this game lasts 50 moves and greco
shows a lot of really advanced concepts
that uh you know people just like didn't
have time to to be taught it just chess
wasn't around long enough so i wanted to
look at this game for for that reason
so we get a french defense
um and it's an advanced french and greco
immediately goes with c5 so so far so
good c3 is normal knight c6 knight f3
bishop d7 and greco is playing the main
line theory good for him
uh bishop e3 and now he plays this move
c4 so
this move um isn't really played so much
today uh so who knows why
why is c4 not so good yeah brian
right um these days it's better
understood that when white has this
massive center
we really do need to break it down
somehow uh otherwise we'll see how you
can run into trouble uh in this game
actually if you try something like c4 we
need pressure
against the d4 pawn for counter play
instead c4 gets played
uh in the game white goes b3 we get b5
a4
a6 so a lot of tension on these pawns
now and then it's immediately broken
they capture the a file opens we get a
trade and now b takes c4 and now i'm
going to say i think this is the most
impressive move of the game by greco
i think probably many people here myself
included wouldn't think for very long
and then would play b take c4
but greco comes up with this move d
takes c4 so what is d take c4 why would
you ever
capture away from the center like this
what do you guys think
rico had a really nice idea behind it
yeah exactly it opens up this d5 square
which is not the most intuitive thing
right you know it seems like you would
just want to take towards the center and
then you know sort of play over here but
greco is is doing this long-term
planning where he's like well where am i
going to put my pieces and he realizes
that this d5 square is just a beautiful
square for a knight so he plays d takes
c4 opens up his d5 square
and uh go you know is is going to just
try to positionally outplay his opponent
um white plays bishop e2 just to develop
now we do c knight g to e7 and knight d5
so fantastic idea by greco and black is
now just a lot better out of the opening
we get bishop to e2 or bishop to d2
stepping away from uh the knight and
defending the pawn
um greco continues with bishop v7 knight
to g5
and bishop takes g5 so
uh
not my favorite move of the game uh but
i think greco didn't want to see this
knight landing on on these strong
outposts so he decided to kill it while
he still could
now bishop takes g5 and finally castles
bishop to f3 is played and knight to a5
so not not my favorite move either
knight to a5 i think a lot better was um
yeah the idea of of playing h6 and the
point is here after this bishop goes
away
we're going to bring this knight back
and we can support this knight a little
bit better and continue to infiltrate on
this a file
instead though knight to a5 uh white can
and should take this uh knight on d5
queen takes d5 is still a good outpost
and then here is where uh we finally see
the ramifications of this move c4 so
black got a lot out of the opening
by putting this pawn on c4 but long term
you have to be very very very cautious
whenever you give up your tension on the
center and an opening like the french
because these pawns are going to give
white a lot of space in the center and
that's going to lead to some pretty
dangerous attacks so without this
pressure against d4 to keep the white
pieces dealing with your threats
white gets a lot more of a free hand to
kind of come and attack you so white to
move here
how should white have continued in this
game to kind of punish black for this
earlier c4 move
while you're thinking someone in the
chat mentions the game shotranj and yeah
that was one of the
many precursors to chess that is much
older than chess used the chess pieces
but again
slightly different rules
um no black just played queen to d5
and so now how can white launch an
attack
yeah queen to g4 is is exactly right and
now you really kind of see the the
problem here for black these pawns
effectively
cuts black's position in in half you see
this knight this queen and even this
bishop are really unable to help
influence the the king's side these
these pawns in the center are just way
too strong
and you can imagine if this pawn were
back on c5 we'd have all these threats
of of taking on d4
we can bring our knight back and
pressure this center and by breaking
through in the center we're also going
to help out our king but with this pawn
on c4 we just have no way to to really
combat these guys uh and that's the
problem for for black here is there's
not a way to really actively uh attack
these pawns
so after queen to g4 white is
immediately making threats of bishop to
h6 you should do something like king to
h8
and now it's just going to bring in
these other pieces to help attack
knight b3 for example allows this move
knight to e4 and now all of a sudden
greco would have been in quite a bit of
danger um
so that's always an important idea to
keep in mind yes here um
greco like despite having this pawn on
c4 has a great position because his
pieces are all very very well placed but
it can really turn quickly when you have
given up such a big center like this so
something to be aware of so queen to g4
would have been nice instead f4 was our
hero no names uh choice we do go bishop
c6 now making this threat and no name
just goes queen to d2 so definitely
again queen to g4 needed to be played
you need to get active you need to find
counter play instead queen to d2 knight
p3 queen c2
and now greco decides to actually
sacrifice this piece so a bit
unnecessary better was just to try to
infiltrate down here on the a file
so we get a good piece sacrifice now
bishop to e4
and going a bit quickly because we're
low on time
greco sacrifices the piece to try and
make these past pawns worth something
especially with white's bishop a little
bit locked out of
out of the game
and then white comes up with this really
good move actually knight to b3 without
this move i think white would be in in
quite a bit of danger um and here greco
sort of lets his advantage slip he was
doing well with these pawns but after
knight to b3 he just takes
and now after takes takes takes i think
this is one of the first instances of
someone getting caught
on the back rank greco has back rank
issues so he's not able to play the move
b2 effectively winning the game has to
deal with the back rank first that's why
we get h6
and now white is able to stop the pawn
at the cost of a full rook
and so we get potentially the first ever
recorded opposite colored bishop end
game now
what can you tell me about opposite
color bishop end games are they
typically winning or typically drawn
typically drawn is is the stereotype yes
because
um these bishops are operating on
different planes of existence right very
difficult to push this pawn through a
dark square when your light squared
bishop can just never help it get there
and that's the case here if no name were
the best he would have uh been able to
hold this but as always you know never
bet unknown name no name always seems to
to not do well
um and he did end up losing this game he
started off well went with g4 in h3 and
now after h5 he he lets it slip
so the best way to hold the position
here would have been to take on h5
and now we have time to bring our king
in
we can even come to e3
now we're just gonna go h4
and the point is here our bishop can
cover the king's side our king can stop
this pawn from from going any further
and white is going to be able to hold
this without too many difficulties
instead
none made a very human mistake he he
said
i don't want to
ruin my pawn structure like that quote
unquote so instead he ruined his pawn
structure like this and this just gives
up a little bit too much a little too
many weaknesses
um
so
let's see here we get kg6
king f2 bishop d5 king e3 and now this
really interesting move h4 so
uh i i both like and kind of dislike
this move so it's really nice to try and
and pin this pawn to a light square
where your bishop can come after it and
that's actually how greco ends up
winning the game but i think h4 was
actually unnecessary we could just play
this this way
force this pawn to this dark square
and now our king is going to have an
avenue into the position
and white isn't going to be able to hold
all the pawns
but h4 is a good idea
uh just
not quite the right execution and now
after bishop to g2 so sort of white's
last chance he needed to play this move
g6 and go for this end game which is a
little bit harder to hold but i think
should still be drawn
um instead he went bishop f8
and now greco wins the second pawn and
with these two pawns so so far away from
each other white just has no chance
no chance of holding makes the queen
and either white resigned or greco just
stopped writing down the moves uh as as
always
um
so hopefully you guys enjoyed some of
these oldest games of chess ever
recorded again i think that the oldest
one played is either that one by by
damiano or or lucena and they're both a
lot of fun to look at i had a lot of fun
looking at all these games
a lot of them are kind of nonsense but
you can really see glimmers of a pretty
sophisticated chess strategy uh coming
coming through in these games
um coming up right after me is woman
grandmaster talia cervantes so please
stick around for for her lecture should
be a lot of fun
as always my name is caleb denby thank
you all very much for coming out and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you